Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Hiya, hiya!
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
1 cm sind 1,75.
Also immer wenn ich mir meine Größe in Inches merken will, dann sage ich einfach 69 Inches.
Nice, ja.
Leute, die vor 20 Inches sind, glaube ich, das wird nichts.
Du bist hier über 10 Meter.
Der Pater Ohrherli ist wieder am Start. 20 Monate Massive Subscription.
Dankeschön.
Huge, huge Leak.
Ja, ja, ich trage das schon recht.
Krasser Leak.
Und soll ich euch mal wirklich, soll ich euch mal was zeigen, was mich vorhin echt aufgeregt hat?
Die Pisser.
Oh, ist das schon Monka Toss?
Darf man das überhaupt sagen auf Twitch?
Du bist ja mittlerweile enorm sensitiv, was sowas angeht, aber das sind echt Pisser.
Passt mal auf hier.
Guckt euch das an.
Hier.
Also, Story ist folgendes.
Letztens wollte ich mal bei eBay Kleinanzeigen gucken.
Ob die gebrauchte Access Points haben.
Also habe ich bei eBay Kleinanzeigen reingeguckt, habe gesehen, ach ja, da gibt es ja was.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, weißt du was, machst du dir mal einen Account.
Und dann wollte ich mir bei eBay Kleinanzeigen einen Account anlegen, gebe meine E-Mail Adresse ein.
Da sagt mir, ja, sie haben schon ein Konto.
Aber dieses Konto ist irgendwie, weiß gar nicht, was ich gesagt habe.
Da stand nicht gesperrt.
Nee, da stand, der Zugriff auf ihr Konto ist eingeschränkt.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, was?
Ich habe kein Konto, ich habe nie ein Konto angelegt.
Was wollen die von mir?
Das Schmoll Access Point ist auch am Start.
Moin.
Da dachte ich mir, was wollen die von mir?
Also, Support geschrieben, sinngemäß sowas reingeschrieben.
Wie also, ich verwende eBay Kleinanzeigen nicht.
Aber eBay verwende ich regelmäßig und ich bezahle da auch immer.
Und, ähm, warum ist mein Konto eingeschränkt?
Was ist da los?
Habe ich ihnen geschrieben an den Support.
Und ich habe heute, ich habe noch nie, ohne Scheiß.
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich die frecheste Support-Mail auf so eine Anfrage aller Zeiten.
Denkt dran, ich habe kein Konto.
Ich habe nichts dort.
Les euch diese Antwort mal durch.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Nachricht.
Die Anmeldung über Ihr Nutzerkonto ist nicht mehr möglich.
Ach was, ich habe gar kein Userkonto.
Ich wollte wissen, warum.
Sagt, dass ich ein Userkonto habe.
Diese Entscheidung ist endgültig.
Wir bitten Sie daher, Abstand von unserem Marktplatz zu nehmen.
Weitere Anfragen Ihrerseits werden wir gerne zur Kenntnis nehmen, die Sie jedoch nicht mehr beantworten.
Alter, diese arroganten Pisser, guckt es euch mal an.
Ich meine, ich bin jetzt bisher, weiß nicht wie lange, es gibt 10 Jahre oder so.
Ich bin 10 Jahre, ich bin 10 Jahre ohne diese Kackplattform ausgekommen.
Ich habe eigentlich gar nicht vor, die großartig zu finden.
Aber was für Pisser, man.
Was ist das für ein arroganter Spastenverein, man.
Wie kann das sein?
Wie kann man so darauf antworten?
Ich habe ganz normal hingeschrieben und gesagt, Jungs, was für ein Account.
Ich habe keinen Account angelegt und ich meine ernsthaft.
Es wäre doch durchaus möglich gewesen, dass ich irgendwann mal meine E-Mail Adresse geleakt habe.
Und irgendjemand versucht hat, sich mit meiner E-Mail Adresse anzumelden, Leute zu scammen oder was auch immer.
Ja, das muss man den Leuten doch sagen.
Jetzt, guck mal, ich meine, du fragst dahin, was ist mit meinem Userkonto los?
Ich habe doch gar keine, da kriegst du so eine Antwort.
Das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen.
Ich habe extra den Namen von dem Mitarbeiter weggemacht unten.
Das muss ja nicht sein.
Alter, was für Pisser.
Das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn.
Das habe ich wirklich noch nicht erlebt.
So eine Antwort.
Also das ist wirklich schlimm.
Das ist heftig.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt auf 69 Likes, so muss das sein.
Bin mal gespannt, ob die noch in irgendeiner Art und Weise reagieren.
Das ist richtig, richtig voll Spaß, ein Support.
Also das ist der Wahnsinn.
Also so frech, so frech vom Support war noch nicht mal, keine Ahnung, noch nicht mal 1 zu 1 damals.
Wirklich Wahnsinn.
Also was mit denen los ist, weiß ich echt nicht.
Dann verwende ich den Scheiß halt nicht.
Ich meine nicht, dass man es wirklich brauchen würde.
So, was ist denn das hier?
Was haben wir denn da auf?
Nee, das brauchen wir nicht.
Recht, du hast leider verpasst.
Hier guck, die E-Mail habe ich bekommen vom ebay-Kleinanzeigen-Support.
Hast du in einem E-Mail-Verlauf eine Bestätigung, dass das Konto mal eröffnet wurde?
Nö.
Ich habe tatsächlich eine E-Mail von ebay-Kleinanzeigen, aber nicht, dass irgendwie ein Konto...
Ich habe extra nach Kleinanzeigen gesucht in meinem Postfach.
Also ich habe keine Nachricht zu nach dem Motto, herzlich willkommen bei ebay-Kleinanzeigen oder sowas.
Wir bitten sie daher Abstand von unserem Marktplatz zu nehmen.
Alter, ich war noch nie auf eurem kack Marktplatz.
Wahnsinn, echt Wahnsinn.
Okay, okay, ich gucke jetzt mal, Leute, ich gucke mal nebenbei.
Ich suche jetzt noch mal meine Mails durch nach ebay-Kleinanzeigen.
Also ich kann jetzt ja eine Suche eingeben hier auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Das dauert jetzt 20 Sekunden.
Da kann ich es euch sagen.
Also ich nehme die gleiche E-Mail, die ich auch verwendet habe, wenn ich versucht habe anzumelden.
Oh, Leute, ich habe eine E-Mail.
Das ist ja geil.
Moment, das kann ich euch nicht zeigen.
Das ist fast schon Scam.
Ich habe eine E-Mail von Amazon und Amazon sagt, ich bin ein Gewinner.
Das klingt sehr, ganz, ganz wenig sass.
Also Kleinanzeigen suche ich jetzt mal.
Kleinanzeigen.
Okay, Probleme einloggen.
Ja, okay, das war ein Ticket.
Also was ich habe, E-Mails mit ebay-Kleinanzeigen.
PC-Welt-Werbung.
Werbung.
Guck mal, ich habe was.
E-Bay-Kleinanzeigen.
Kostenlos, einfach lokal.
Leute, 14.
März aktiviere jetzt dein E-Bay-Kleinanzeigen-Konto.
Aber soll mir das jetzt sagen?
Aktiviere jetzt dein E-Bay-Kleinanzeigen-Konto, habe ich geklickt, am 14.
März mit einer Bestätigungslink.
Das heißt, es hat sich jemand versucht, mit meiner E-Mail-Adresse zu registrieren, was
ja aber nicht funktioniert hat, weil ich habe definitiv nie diesen Link angeklickt und ich
habe auch keine Bestätigungs-E-Mail.
Ja, aber das müssen die mir doch sagen.
Stellt euch mal vor, jemand hat wirklich meine E-Mail geklaut und darüber Leute gescampt.
Das müssen die mir doch mitteilen.
Die müssen mir das doch sagen.
Also die müssen mir doch sagen, was Sache ist.
Vielleicht hat jemand Leute in meinem Namen gescampt.
Das müssen die mir doch sagen.
Ich habe in der E-Mail geschrieben, ich hatte noch nie einen E-Bay-Kleinanzeigen-Konto.
Noch nie.
Ich habe diese Plattform noch nie verwendet.
Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, es hat sich wirklich jemand mit meiner E-Mail-Adresse
angemeldet und hat versucht, die Leute zu scammen.
Ja, btf.
Das ist ein unfähiger Kackladen, man.
Warum sind alle so scheiß unfähig?
Was soll das?
Das triggert mich immer richtig.
Nicht, weil die so unfreundlich sind, nein, weil die so unfähig sind alle.
An überall gibt es Amateure, wo du hinguckst, in Bereichen, wo es eigentlich keine geben
sollte.
Ja, richtig.
Wub-S.
Wub-Rage.
Ganz schlimm.
Haben die noch?
Ich rufe da nicht an.
Ich garantiert rufe ich da nicht an.
Ne.
Aber die E-Mail, aber die Antwort ist frech, oder?
Also die Antwort ist wirklich richtig frech.
Die müssen doch selbst auf die Idee kommen, dass man vielleicht gescannt, also dass man
jemand anderes E-Mail-Adresse, wenn ich schon so doof frage, so ich habe keinen Account,
wie kommt das überhaupt, dass es gesperrt ist?
Meine Güte.
Ja, das frage ich mich auch.
Das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Ich habe den Bestätigungs-E-Mail, also das ist die einzige E-Mail, die ich habe.
Wenn ich nochmal geklickt hätte, hätte ich ja irgendwas gekriegt.
Nix.
Ich habe auch keinerlei E-Mails bekommen, mit, ähm, dass das irgendwas gemacht wurde
oder so.
Das ist legit die einzige Sache, die ich bekommen habe von E-Mail-Kleinanzeigen.
Sonst habe ich nichts, nur Werbung.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Also ultra hängen geblieben, Alter.
So, ist Apple eigentlich durch?
Guck mal ob heise was zu Apple geschrieben hat.
iOS 16 und M2 wurde vorgestellt.
Aha.
Welche neuen Produkte stellt Apple auf der WWDC heute vor?
Ne, das interessiert mich nicht.
Wo ist das Update?
Nein, nein, keine externen Inhalte laden.
Monk S.
Ne.
Also falls einer eine gute Zusammenfassung kennt, dann sagt Bescheid.
Das Game.
Welches Game?
Das Game ist super.
Geil.
Heise.
Top.
Weiß von sofort Bescheid.
Was würdest du eher für ein Fullstack Framework verwenden?
Zwerg und Nuxt.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kenne Nuxt nicht.
Also ich habe schon mit Vue öfters was gemacht, aber ich habe noch nie Nuxt verwendet.
Ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich würde ich Nuxt verwenden, wenn das wirklich was sein soll,
wo ich nicht alleine dran arbeite oder eben was, was, sagen wir mal, ja, wirklich auch
getestet sein muss und bessere Library-Auswahl hat und sonst was.
Also wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich würde ich Nuxt nehmen, einfach weil das größer,
bekannter ist und es mehr Ressourcen zu gibt.
Ich persönlich, wenn nur ich dran arbeite, würde ich das nehmen, weil ich mich damit
mehr auskenne.
Ist Mikrotik, die als Mikrotik nicht tech, Mikrotik eine gescheite Routermarke?
Ja.
Kommt darauf an, was du machen willst.
Also wenn du einfach nur quasi sagst, ich brauche einen Fritzbox-Ersatz oder einen,
nee Fritzbox-Ersatz ist es ja nicht.
Ich brauche einfach was, was ein bisschen mehr Router ist als die Fritzbox.
Im Heimbereich, also es ist definitiv kein Einsteigergerät.
Also Mikrotik-Geräte mit Router-OS sind auf jeden Fall keine Einsteigergeräte.
Also da hast du ein bisschen Paintschamp, das zu konfigurieren, wenn du es noch nicht
gemacht hast.
Übrigens, weder Swellkit noch Nux ist wirklich Fullstack würde ich sagen.
Ich meine, du kannst Server-side-rendering was machen und dann da theoretisch auch irgendwas
abrufen.
Aber wenn du ein API-Backend brauchst, brauchst du ja sonst noch irgendwas dazu.
Was heißt Fullstack, Frontend und Backend?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe noch nie als Junior-Fullstack gearbeitet, ich habe keinen Schimmer.
Das kommt wahrscheinlich wie immer auf die üblichen Sachen an.
Wo du bist, was es genau für Technologien ist, wie gefragt das Ganze ist, solche Sachen.
So, übrigens um jetzt nochmal dazu was zu sagen, ich bin wirklich happy, dass das so
gut funktioniert mit dem Abnehmen.
Ich mache gar nicht so viel.
Ich esse, ehrlich gesagt hauptsächlich mache ich zwei Sachen.
Ich bewege mich mehr als früher.
Und ich meine, man kann sich das kaum vorstellen, aber ich habe heute morgen mal im Bad so runtergeguckt.
Also nicht das was, nicht was ihr denkt jetzt, nein.
Ich habe heute morgen im Bad so mal runtergeguckt und habe meine Füße gesehen.
Und habe festgestellt, wie weiß meine Füße im Vergleich zu den Beinen sind.
Und da ist mir mal aufgefallen, ich habe dieses Jahr so viel Hautfarbe wie noch die
noch nie kann ich nicht sagen.
Früher war ich ja viel draußen.
Aber sagen wir mal, wie die letzten 15 Jahre nicht mehr.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich mache eigentlich hauptsächlich zwei Sachen.
Ich bewege mich mehr.
Und essen tue ich immer noch ganz normale Mengen.
Was ich mache ist, ich esse etwas weniger Fett.
Ein bisschen weniger Fett.
Also jetzt nicht erst noch mal, was weiß ich, die Frikadelle warm gemacht und danach erstmal
in der Pfanne noch vorher Fett rein gehauen, sondern man kann die auch so warm machen.
Das ist eine Nintendo Mario Playlist.
Hier, Songs and Smiles, Happy and Upbeat Nintendo Music Mix.
Das stimmt, das habe ich ja letztens schon als Indikator gesagt.
Also es gibt eigentlich einen universellen Check, wenn man ein Kerl ist, wie viel zu fett
man ist.
Man stellt sich in die Dusche und guckt nach unten.
So.
Und dann ist die Frage, wie viel man von seinem Teil noch sieht.
Sieht man seinen Teil, ist alles in Ordnung, ist absolut in Ordnung das Gewicht.
Wenn man sich nach vorne biegen muss, dann kommt es auf den Grad an, wie weit man sich
nach vorne biegen muss, dass man wieder sieht.
Also nicht nach vorne biegen, sondern nur den Kopf und den Hals nach vorne machen.
Und wenn man es nicht schafft, durch rein Hals und Kopf nach vorne zu machen, so weit
zu kommen, dass man seinen Teil wieder sieht, dann ist man viel zu fett.
So kann man so als pauschal sagen.
Sag mal Max, wie habt ihr das bei euch auf der Arbeit mit Videocalls?
Macht ihr Videocalls mit Cam?
Mein Anruf ist ja, dass das so ein Boomer-Ding ist.
Ja, nee, nee, nee.
Ich mache keine Cam an.
Einziges Mal, wenn ich die Cam anmache, ist, was weiß ich, wenn ich in irgendeiner Runde
bin, wo halt auch irgendwelche Boomer-Leute sind.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wir haben beispielsweise einmal die Woche so eine Abteilungsrunde, da war ich jetzt schon
öfters mal als Vertretung für meinen Chef oder halt mit meinem Chef da.
Und das hat so einen offiziellen Charakter.
Da haben sie auch immer alle die Kamera an.
Da mache ich dann auch die Kamera an.
Aber normalerweise, wenn ich so ins Teams rangehe, nicht mit Kamera und nix.
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe hier extra ein Hemd hängen.
Was ich mir anziehen kann, wenn solche Meetings sind.
Da ziehe ich das Hemd an.
Dann sieht das so aus, als sitze ich hier ganz furchtbar büßnend vorm Rechner.
Und wenn das fertig ist, schmeiße ich das Hemd wieder in die Ecke und sitze dann hier
in Schlafwahn zu hohes vorm Rechner.
Deswegen mache ich normalerweise auch keine Kamera an und nix.
So mache ich das.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ich lese mir dann eine Zusammenfassung durch.
Wie gesagt, die letzten Events, ganz im Ernst, die letzten Apple Events waren nicht sonderlich
spannend.
Das ist Update vom Update und im Endeffekt riesen Hype generieren um nichts oder um wenig.
Das trifft im Prinzip, ich weiß, ich hatte jemand von euch ein bisschen Microsoft Bild
2022 geguckt.
Das war ja vor zwei Wochen oder so.
Und ich muss sagen, also dieses Jahr war die schlechteste Bild, die sie je gemacht haben.
Da war kaum was dabei, was mich interessiert hat.
Also, ich habe mir die Bild sonst immer gerne angeguckt, weil da gab es gerade was dotnet
angeht.
Bild ist die Microsoft, Microsoft Entwickler Konferenz.
Das ist eigentlich die größte, die Microsoft Entwickler Konferenz.
Und so zumindest, ich habe mir da so durchgeguckt.
Normalerweise, normalerweise gab es da immer Sachen, neue C-Sharp-Version, was gibt es
Neues, gab es dieses Jahr auch.
Interessante Sachen dabei gewesen.
Da gab es ASP.NET, was gibt es Neues.
Dann gab es dotnet-internals, was gibt es Neues.
Da gab es hier und da super interessante Geschichten und ich habe mir bestimmt jede
Bild 15, 20 Sessions angeguckt als Watt.
Dieses Jahr gab es genau zwei Sessions, die ich geguckt habe.
Das ist was, gibt es Neues in C-Sharp und das ist dotnet-ahead-of-time-kompilation oder
sowas.
Diese zwei Sachen habe ich mir angeguckt und der Rest, Leute, wartet mal.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das jetzt hier so erkennt.
Die Themen auf der Bild dieses Jahr waren ganz weird, Champ.
Ich meine, wie gesagt, das ist ein Entwickler.
Ich reakte nicht auf das Apple-Ding.
Ne, nachdem die mich mal gestrikt haben, mache ich da gar nichts mehr.
Die können mich mal pickern, Alter.
Schon die zweiten heute.
So, MyBild hatten die doch.
Wo ist es denn?
Microsoft hat es auch nicht so mit den Webseiten, oder?
Ich will mir die Watts angucken.
MyBild 2020.
Hier, da ist es doch.
Man darf nicht vergessen, das hier ist eigentlich eine Entwickler-Konferenz.
Da soll es um neue Technologien gehen, von Programmiersprachen bis Runtimes bis Windows-Cloud-Gedöns,
alles möglich von Microsoft.
Kann die Seite mal laden heute noch?
Microsoft.
Webseite laden, please.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert es.
Die Seite ist ein bisschen kaputt, ja.
So, und 300 MB JavaScript.
Die Webseite laggt erst.
Sag mal, was ist denn?
WTF?
Das ist eine 5 FPS-Webseite.
Was hat denn Microsoft hier wieder getrieben?
So, und dann konnte man die Sessions hier bei Microsoft durchsuchen.
Session-Katalog.
So, und dann kann man auswählen, was man haben will.
Und da sind schon ein paar interessante Sessions dabei.
Aber für mich dieses Jahr ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich viel.
Da waren jede Menge Metaverse-Bullshit dabei.
Da waren irgendwelche komischen Asher-Dinger, die wirklich gar keinen interessieren.
Dann hatten sie auch so ein paar ganz komische Dinge, wo ich mich frage,
was hat das auf der Bild zu tun?
So was weiß ich.
Was hatten sie da so irgendwie?
Über autistische Programmierer und feministische Programmierer und sowas in der Richtung.
Das mögen ja Themen sein, die an sich vielleicht ganz interessant sind.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich das auf einer Technik-Entwickler-Konferenz wirklich brauche.
Guckt so Dinger hier.
Gleichheit und Inklusion in Produkten und so.
Ja, ist ja okay.
Aber ich will wissen, wie ist die neue Property-Funktion in C-Sharp unter der Haube implementiert,
dass ich jetzt Felder nicht mehr definieren muss und trotzdem darauf zugreifen kann.
Das will ich auf einer Bild sehen.
Und nicht unbedingt so Dinger.
Und ansonsten ist sehr viel langweiliges Zeug dieses Jahr auf der Bild gewesen.
Low-Code-Tools ist auch sowas.
Könnte mich nicht weniger interessieren.
Wer sich fragt, was ist ein Low-Code-Tool?
Zum Beispiel Battlefield Portal, dieser Blockly-Editor.
Das ist so ähnlich was wie ein Low-Code-Tool.
Es ist so viel langweiliges Zeug dabei, wenn man diese Talks dieses Jahr durchguckt.
Preparing for the Metaverse.
Was ein Bullshit.
Das klinge ich noch nicht mal an.
Also es war wirklich enttäuschend für mich dieses Jahr.
Highlight für mich auf der Bild dieses Jahr eindeutig wieder.
Allein schon, dass man hier nicht gescheit nach Themengebieten mehr filtern kann.
Du kannst hier drin schon aber nicht sagen, hier Topic.
Wie sieht es mit.NET Plattform aus?
Nö, gibt es einfach nicht.
.NET Plattform?
Was ist das für ein Topic?
Es gab auch kaum Expert-Talks und sowas.
Das fand ich alles ein bisschen schwach, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Du findest eh nichts, was es wirklich sein soll.
Also mein Highlight dieses Jahr war eindeutig mal wieder der Talk von dem Ober-C-Sharp-Man,
der die neuen Funktionen vorgestellt hat.
Hat eigentlich über Kleinanzeigen reagiert?
Nö.
Dieses heutige Feiertag reagieren die wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Ansonsten war es wirklich enttäuschend dieses Jahr die Bild.
Das fand ich sehr langweilig.
Der Ernährungskompass.
Okay, das sagt uns jetzt.
Fett macht nicht fett.
Okay, das hilft bei mir aber weniger fettig futtern.
Ich meine das Fett nicht fett macht an sich.
Also wenn ich jetzt einen Esslöffel Fett am Tag zu mir nehme und sonst halt kaum was,
ja meinetwegen, dann wird mich das wahrscheinlich nicht fett machen.
Aber wenn ich normales Zeug esse, besonders fettig, da hat das ja auch wie viel mehr Kalorien,
das macht dich im Prinzip dann unterm Strich schon fett.
Und das hilft bei mir.
Mehr bewegen, weniger fettig essen.
Aber ich futter immer noch, Leute, ich futter immer noch Massive Portionen.
Was heißt Massive?
Ich esse normale Portionen.
Ich muss auch normale Portionen essen, weil wenn ich nicht normale Portionen esse,
dann halte ich das gar nicht durch.
Ich meine, ich mache das jetzt schon seit über drei Monaten mit mehr bewegen und essen.
Und weniger fettig essen.
Und das hilft, ich meine, es sind jetzt ziemlich genau 11 Kilo, die ich abgenommen habe.
Kannst dich nicht beschweren.
Ich glaube, Apple entwickelt ihr eigenes Office 365 mit Collaboration in der Cloud und so.
Ja, wenn es eine gute Zusammenfassung gibt, falls Heise oder Golem oder irgendwer was hat,
können wir zusammen gucken.
Aber ich gucke mir kein Apple-Video-Material mehr hier im Stream an.
Das haben sie sich verkackt.
iOS 16 stellt das iPhone auf den Kopf.
Okay, Golem, erzähl.
Das neue iOS für iPhone folgt.
Optisch... na gut.
Dass das Ding ein bisschen optisch verändert wird, ist ja normal.
Aber eins muss man sagen, das kann Apple wirklich gut.
Da muss man Apple auch mal loben.
Man muss jetzt kein großer Apple-Fan sein, aber das kann Apple wirklich gut.
Ich meine jetzt nicht das Design und so, das ist Geschmackssache,
wobei ich das persönlich relativ ansprechend finde vom iPhone.
Aber eine Sache kann Apple wirklich gut.
Und das ist es ihre Sicht.
Und das ist es ihre Systeme kontinuierlich vom Design her fresh halten,
ohne diese komische in die Pfanne zu tappen, wie das teilweise Microsoft macht,
mit neuen Versionen alles anders oder an den Stellen, wo es die Leute abfuckt anders.
Apple hat das geschafft relativ fließend von...
wenn man sich mal so die Entwicklung anguckt von iOS,
vom ersten iOS bis zum aktuellen iOS,
relativ fließend die Updates zu machen,
so dass die Leute selten, ich will nicht sagen nie, aber selten gesagt haben,
oh Alter, das ist jetzt ja komplett anders, oh nee, das halte ich ja nicht aus,
so wie man das bei Windows 11 macht.
Sondern die haben es geschafft wirklich das so Häppchen, Häppchen weiter immer fresh zu halten.
Also das macht Apple wirklich gut.
Und man muss ihm sagen, was für Apple auch noch gut macht ist,
die haben klare Vorgaben.
Ich meine, das ist nicht wie die im App Store umgehen, weil das ist nicht klar,
aber die haben klare Vorgaben, wie eine App auszusehen hat,
wenn man sich an den Apple Style halten möchte.
Du kannst dir das genau angucken und du kannst auch sagen, jawoll,
ich mache eine macOS App und ich verwende das offizielle macOS Toolkit dafür
und dann sieht das Ding aus wie eine macOS App und lässt sich gut programmieren
und lässt sich schön in macOS integrieren.
Nicht wie unter Windows, wo du 15 verschiedene Möglichkeiten hast,
von Windows Forms bis WPF über UWP bis WinUI 3 hast du nicht gesehen alles
und keiner ist wirklich gut davon.
Also das kann Apple auch nicht schlecht.
Das muss man denen wirklich lassen, also das kriegen sie hin,
ansonsten machen die auch viel fragwürdige Sachen.
Also das ist der Sperrbildschirm.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass die dann da drauf ist, die ganze Zeit,
wenn man so komisch anguckt.
Also was gibt es Neues?
Das Neue, der von Lutz dann stärker angepasst werden kann,
Schriftenfarben, na gut.
Ganz ehrlich, der Sperrbildschirm ist, ähm,
jetzt eines der Sachen, die gucke ich mir am wenigsten an.
Man guckt zwar rein, immer, um zum Entsperren,
aber ich verwende auch keine Widgets oder so, denn das einzige Widget,
was ich habe, ist Home Assistant Actions ein paar.
Aber ansonsten hält sich sehr in Grenzen meine Widgets Verwendung.
Neue Sperrbildschirm.
Die Widgets ordnen sich unterhalb der Uhr an,
ja, gut, das will ich jetzt nicht alles lesen.
Ich warte, bis es Screenshots gibt.
Gibt es Screenshots?
Heise macht das vielleicht besser.
Das nicht, Tim.
Tim, jepp.
Ich sag's jetzt nicht, sonst geht das noch als Toss durch.
Ich sag jetzt nur Tim, jepp.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
So, Ayo soll persönlicher und schlauer werden.
Ja, gut.
iMessage, Live Text, Apple...
Ja, gut, Apple Maps ist auch so ein Ding, das verwende ich nie.
Ich verwende hauptsächlich Google Maps,
aber ich muss sagen, ich finde die Google Maps Bedienung auch nicht gut.
Google Maps ist teilweise sehr nervig in der Bedienung.
Der Artikel ist ready, den haben die geschrieben während dem BWDC.
Die haben wahrscheinlich fünf Leute sitzen, die sich das angucken
und dann schreiben die Artikel dabei.
Das muss zack, zack, bam, ba-bam gehen.
Naja, ich hab ja nicht umsonst mal eine BWL-Ausbildung gemacht.
Auch wenn ich davon nichts mehr...
Also...
Wir wollen jetzt nicht weiter darüber sprechen, okay?
Die haben einen One-Note-Rip-Off vorgestellt.
Wer, Apple oder Microsoft, wieder mal?
Nein, hab ich nicht geguckt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob die da drauf reagieren.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Leute, zu 3000 Kalorien am Tag, ich weiß nicht.
Ist das viel, ist das wenig, ich weiß nicht.
Ich hatte mal einen Kollege auf der Arbeit.
Das hab ich, glaub ich, schon mal erzählt.
Recycled Story, geh ich mal von aus.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das schon erzählt hab.
Der hat immer die Armlehnen abgesprengt vom Stuhl,
weil er nicht auf den Stuhl gepasst hat.
Und ich hab mich das erste Mal gefragt, als ich da reingekommen bin,
warum ist hier ein Stuhl mit so Armlehnen, die ab waren?
Also, Bürostuhl...
So nur nach 15 Bürostuhl war das.
Ja, im Prinzip sowas hier, ja.
Sowas hier in der Richtung war das.
Und der hat es geschafft, die Armlehnen abzusprengen,
dass die dann, die hingen nur noch hier unten so dran.
Hab ich gedacht, was ist denn da los, Alter?
Also, der war wirklich sehr massiv.
Sehr massiv.
Und der hat bestimmt...
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob 3000 Kalorien viel sind,
aber der hat bestimmt locker 3000 Kalorien am Tag vernichtet.
Der ist immer mittags erst auf die Arbeit gekommen,
weil er nicht mit dem Zug fahren konnte,
weil er an sich reingepasst richtig auf die Plätze dort.
Und dann hat er mittags immer bestellt zu essen.
Und der war dann um elf da und hat Essen bestellt,
dreimal Pizza, zweimal Nudeln, vier Flaschen Cola für den ganzen Tag.
Und das hat er dann gefuttert bis abends
und ist dann 21 Uhr wieder heimgefahren.
Und das dann jeden Tag in der Woche.
Und...
Der war halt, der war hardcore.
Also, der hat es.
Aber, muss ich auch dazu sagen, irgendwann...
Ähm, ist er auf, ist er in eine Selbsthilfegruppe gegangen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das 3000 Kalorien sind.
Keine Ahnung, ob viele oder wenige sind.
Ist wahrscheinlich deutlich mehr.
Also, der ist irgendwann in eine Essstörung-Selbsthilfegruppe gegangen.
Und dort, das sah, das hab ich mir gemerkt,
das sah schon erstmal, ja, präglant aus, ja.
Also, der hatte dann dort jemand kennengelernt,
die hatte auch Essstörung.
Und...
Ich hab die beiden dann auf der Weihnachtsfeier getroffen.
Und die saß bei ihm auf dem Oberschenkel.
Und die war quasi exakt so...
Also, die gesamte Frau war so breit,
komplett, insgesamt, so breit wie sein, einer Oberschenkel.
Also, er war extrem dick.
Und sie war wirklich extremst dünn.
Also quasi...
Ihr Bein passt zweimal in seinen Arm, so nach dem Motto, ja.
Also, die hat bei ihm auf dem Oberschenkel gesessen.
Und die war genauso breit wie der Oberschenkel.
Es war quasi so eine Liege, fast schon.
Ja, aber man muss halt sagen, das hat ihm wirklich gut getan.
Er hat übertrieben abgenommen,
seit er in diese Selbsthilfegruppe gegangen ist.
Und ob sie zugenommen hat, hab ich keine Ahnung.
Den hab ich ein paar Jahre später,
wieder gesehen, da hat er bestimmt 70 kg abgenommen oder so.
Aber war immer noch massiv.
Also, der Kerl da war wirklich richtig dick ursprünglich mal.
Und wenn die beiden...
Wenn die beiden quasi einfach nur...
Also, wenn sie einfach nur das Doppelte gegessen hat von davor
und er nur die Hälfte gegessen hat von dem wie davor,
dann haben die wahrscheinlich beide gewonnen, ja.
Wann nimmst du ab? Ich bin auch grad schon dabei.
Ich hab schon 11 kg abgenommen.
Ich hoffe ja, dass ich es irgendwie schaffe,
wenn ich so weitermache, dass ich bis Ende des Jahres eventuell...
Wobei das... Na, mal gucken.
Ob ich es vielleicht schaffe bis Ende des Jahres unter 90.
Das würde mir schon komplett reichen.
Mehr will ich nicht.
Unter 90 bin ich zufrieden.
Dann wiege ich wieder ungefähr das,
was ich so nach dem ersten Jahr meiner Ausbildung gewogen habe.
Ich hab halt extrem zugenommen.
Ich bin 69 Inches.
Kannste ausrechnen, wie groß das in Zentimeter ist.
Ja, also, wie gesagt, ich hab, als ich angefangen hab...
Mit der Ausbildung war ich noch nicht so pepo fett, ja.
Und ich hab dann richtig krass zugenommen in der Ausbildung.
Und vor allem, als ich fertig war.
Es macht halt einen Unterschied, ob du einen Bürojob hast
und noch daheim am Rechner sitzt.
Also, ich hab ja quasi...
Wenn man mal so früher guckt,
auch danach die ersten paar Jahre nach der Ausbildung...
Ich hab quasi...
8 Stunden auf der Arbeit vorm Rechner gesessen.
Bin heimgekommen und hab jetzt übertrieben gesagt,
noch mal 8 Stunden vorm Rechner gesessen.
Nein, nicht ganz. Geht ja nicht.
Aber von 16 noch was bis 2, 2, 6 Stunden.
Das war halt eigentlich nur Rumgesitze.
Und ich hab das irgendwann auch gemerkt,
dass mir der Rücken weh tut, dass ich Kreislaufprobleme hab.
Und ich frag mich halt immer, wie ist das für Leute?
Früher war ich relativ sportlich.
Ich konnte kilometerweit schwimmen.
Das hat mich überhaupt nicht geschockt.
Ich bin erst so richtig pepofett geworden,
seit ich die Ausbildung gemacht hab.
Ich frag mich halt... Sagen wir mal so.
Ich hab angefangen zuzunehmen so mit...
Keine Ahnung...
17, 18 oder so.
Also ich sag mal...
Oder mit 20, mehr mit 20.
Mit 20 hab ich angefangen ein bisschen zuzunehmen.
So richtig zugenommen hab ich erst mit 25.
Also ich bin jetzt quasi nur...
Ja...
Sag mal nur 12 bis...
Sag mal 15 Jahre.
Ich bin jetzt nur 15 Jahre zu dick gewesen.
Und...
Ich frag mich, wie das für Leute ist in meinem Alter,
die schon ihr Leben lang zu dick sind.
Und ich hatte schon Probleme. Wie ist das dann erst für welche,
die quasi schon seit sie 2 Jahre alt sind, übertrieben gesagt zu dick sind?
Dann hast du doch von Knie bis Rücken bis sonst was.
Dann bist du doch voll im Arsch schon mit 37.
Hast du denn vor der Ausbildung Sport gemacht?
Also ich hab nicht im Verein oder so.
Also ich war ein bisschen bei Fußballspielen im Verein.
Aber ich war sehr viel schwimmen und ich konnte wirklich...
Ich konnte Kilometer weit schwimmen.
Das hat mich nicht geschockt.
Ich bin im Schwimmbad 100 mal hin und zurück geschwommen.
Dann bin ich raus und hab gedacht, easy.
Man will ein bisschen kühl langsam so nach dem Motto.
Mich alles nicht geschockt.
Ja, wenn man zu dick ist, ist Schwimmen angeblich gut,
weil das nicht so sehr auf die Gelenke geht.
Hast du keinen Bock wieder zu schwimmen?
Hölzchengrenzen.
Ich habe mir belegt, ob ich dir ein Fahrrad kaufen soll.
Ja, ach ja, ein Fun-Fact noch zu PepeFat.
Als ich angefangen hab, sodass man sich das ungefähr mal vom Verhältnis vorstellen kann.
Als ich angefangen habe mit meiner Ausbildung,
wurde ich und ein Jahr später, da Felix auch,
die haben uns in Netzwerk-Elektronik-Räume reingeschickt,
weil es dort...
Hast du nicht einen Fahrrad-Krill getroffen?
Doch, hab ich.
Letztens beim Wandern hab ich einen Fahrrad-Krill getroffen.
Merkt ihr euch Leute, was ich hier erzähle?
Was ist da?
Ich kann Boxen empfehlen, ja.
Boxen ist Pog.
Rudern.
Nee, ähm, das wollte ich jetzt sagen, ja.
Also, die haben Felix und mich damals immer
noch in Netzwerk-Technik-Räume, in Elektronik-Räume geschickt,
weil wir die einzigen waren im Team damals, die da reingepasst haben.
Das waren quasi so ganz kleine Seitenräume,
die mehr oder weniger genauso breit waren,
wie die Tür, die reingegangen ist.
Also, da war eine Tür irgendwo ganz hinten in einem Gang,
und da ging es in so einen Elektronik-Raum,
Etagenverteiler-Raum rein,
und der war halt exakt so breit wie die Tür,
bloß dass in dem Raum selbst noch Switche hingen und so was,
hochkant, hab ich dann auch nie wieder gesehen,
Switche hochkant aufgehängt.
Und da haben die uns damals reingeschickt,
weil wir die einzigen im Team waren,
die an diesen Switches und dieser Technik
reingepasst haben und was machen konnten,
ohne dass wir es runtergerissen hätten.
Paar Jahre später hätte ich da auch nicht mehr reingepasst.
Nee, das war gar nicht so sehr, lass es den Azubi machen,
das war wirklich auch bestimmt,
aber das war wirklich, weil die nicht reingepasst haben.
Und ich hab damals easy reingepasst.
Der Felix auch, und mittlerweile passen wir da beide nicht mehr rein.
Obwohl, ich passe vielleicht bald mal wieder rein, ja,
wenn es so weitergeht.
Ja, das ist, das ist Gewöhnungssache.
Ich hab auch ein iPhone als Dienst-Handy,
Firmen-Handy, wie man es nennen mag.
Ich komm damit auch ganz gut klar.
Es gibt ein paar Dinge, da werde ich mich
wahrscheinlich nicht dran gewöhnen, aber,
Salad-Apple-Style.
Ein Beispiel, wie manche Settings angeordnet sind,
das ist unlogisch.
Warum wurde meine BWL-Karriere beendet?
Weil ich BWL richtigen Abfang fand.
Ich hatte überhaupt keinen Bock.
Ich hab ja mal, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schon mal erzähle,
ich hab ja mal Bürokauf mal angefangen zu lernen, ja.
So ganz, ganz, ganz lange her.
Weil Mutter und Vater und so meinten,
man muss jetzt mal was Gescheites machen,
und kann nicht nur daheim rum sitzen und den ganzen Tag
MMO-Kreisel grinden und sowas.
Da hab ich Bürokauf mal angefangen.
Leute, das war eine sehr schlechte Entscheidung.
Und...
Also, ich war nicht glücklich in dieser Zeit.
Und ich hab das dann abgebrochen, das hab ich nicht...
Nee, ich denk da auch nicht gerne dran.
Hättest du den MMO-Kreisel grind gestreamt?
Ja, damals gab's noch keine Streams, das war 2000...
Keine Ahnung, 3000?
Das war noch vor World of Warcraft,
3? Das war noch vor World of Warcraft Release, Alter.
Damals haben alle mit FRAPS aufgenommen.
Was machen die Stonks? Sekunde.
Leute, ich checke meine Stonks.
Scalable, zeig her, Face ID.
Meine Stonks sagen plus 135 Euro today.
Die Stonks gehen hoch.
Aber ich bin immer noch im minus 700, äh, nee, 943 Euro.
Das muss noch ein bisschen steigen.
Ich sollte mittlerweile 20 Amazon-Aktien haben, wahrscheinlich, ja.
Na ja.
Wie der Typ von South Park, das finde ich auch witzig.
Die Leute damals haben ganz viele...
Also, ich spiele jetzt auf die World of Warcraft-Episode aus South Park an.
Ich hab damals schon gerne South Park geguckt.
Ich gucke ab und zu heute noch.
Wobei ich sagen muss, das ist jetzt...
Also, so witzig finde ich die letzten paar...
Weiß nicht, wo die jetzt sind, Season 23 oder...
Keine Ahnung. Jetzt nicht mehr.
Sie haben ein paar ganz coole Sachen drin, wo ich noch lachen muss, aber...
Dann habe ich die Luft auch raus, wenn man das jetzt schon seit 20 Jahren guckt.
Zumindest damals dachten die Leute ja ernsthaft, dass South Park sowas ist.
Irgendwie, was weiß ich...
Bestfalls, was mit World of Warcraft erfunden wurde oder so.
Weil die alle nur die World of Warcraft-Folge kannten.
Übrigens, das beste Cosplay aller Zeiten.
Das muss ich sagen.
So gut hat nie wieder einer cosplayt, was ich bisher gesehen habe.
Das ist der South Park...
BoW...
Cosplay.
Der Dude, Alter. Das ist der beste.
Nicht das Elfgrill.
Der Typ, der nächste Typ, das ist der beste.
Bestes Cosplay aller Zeiten.
Da können die ganzen Only-Fan-Cosplaygrills auspacken.
Da kommt keiner dran.
Der Typ sieht exakt aus wie der South Park-Typ.
Der hätte das nicht besser treffen können.
Wahrscheinlich hat er nicht gewonnen.
Der ist tot mittlerweile.
Alter, warum sterben die Leute alle so früh?
Was ist denn los?
Das ist der vierte, der mir einfällt, der in den letzten Jahren gestorben ist.
Der gleich alt wie ich war oder jünger war wie ich.
Was ist denn los?
Es ging los mit Internet-Hulk in Overwatch.
Dann TotalBiscuit.
InControl.
Alter, warum sterben die alle?
Da kriege ich mit Angst zu tun.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass man sich Gedanken machen muss.
Ein Snickers hat 433...
Das ist natürlich...
Wenn man sich überlegt, besteht ein Snickers aus Zucker, Karamell, Fett, Schokoladen.
Das ist ja quasi...
Gramm geworden.
Kalorien quasi.
Was ist denn los?
Zeit für neue Büroeinrichtungen.
Hat Linus?
So was vor seinem Rechner?
Nee, der hat einen Laufband.
Was ist denn das?
Die wollen sich ernsthaft erzählen, dass die Leute so glücklich da sitzen und das dann machen mit der Katze.
Jaja, ist klar natürlich.
Hat Linus nicht einen Laufband vor dem Rechner?
Also ich meine die Linux.
Nicht Tech-Tipps.
Hatte der nicht so einen Laufband vor seinem höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch?
Da kann er, wenn er Colonel-Comments mercht, kann er dann joggen.
Genau der.
Domsdal eigentlich für den Zapp?
Ah ne, hab ich schon vorgelesen, egal.
Doppelt, schadet nichts.
Nick BNX, danke für den Zapp.
Sieben Kiste, Massive Subscriptions hier.
Magst du beim Fahrrad fahren?
Ganz genau.
Boah, das Ding hat mich überhaupt nicht angesprochen.
Ja, das mit den Browsern ist auch nervig unter iOS.
Erstmal gucken, ob es mittlerweile irgendwo gescheite Screenshots von gibt.
Das ist auch nervig.
MacOS Ventura will Passwörter abschaffen.
Da muss man jetzt sagen, wenn Apple das macht...
Das ist auch ein Punkt, den ich ganz gut finde.
Also ich muss sagen, wenn Apple was Neues herausbringt, wirkt das meistens.
Das setzt sich zwar nicht immer durch und es wird dann auch nicht unbedingt für immer beibehalten,
aber wenn Apple was Neues rausbringt, ist das meistens halbwegs durchdacht.
Also die Sachen, die man benutzt, wirken so, als hat sich einer Gedanken gemacht vorher.
Das kann man jetzt bei Microsoft Produkten nicht unbedingt sagen.
Und bei Linux auch nicht wirklich.
Unter Linux denkt man sich die ganze Zeit, ja, der Typ, der das entwickelt hat,
hatte eine Sache im Kopf, nämlich seinen Anwendungsfall.
Und bei Microsoft weiß ich nicht, was die sich denken.
Leider ist das, was Apple sich denkt, oftmals nicht das, was ich gerne hätte.
Aber man merkt Apple Produkten in der Regel schon an, dass da sich jemand Gedanken zugemacht hat
und diese Gedanken irgendwie auch sinnvoll sind.
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt für mich, aber aus Apple Sicht.
Also das muss man denen echt lassen, ja.
Und wenn Apple das schafft, sowas hier zu etablieren, dann wird es nicht lange dauern.
Dann wird es das für alle anderen Betriebssysteme auch geben.
Steht mal wieder ein Stellenanzeigen-Review an?
Ja.
Bestimmt.
Also das neue Apple-Betrieb Mac OS Ventura erlaubt die Nutzung des iPhones als Webcam.
Bietet eine... Moment, man kann das iPhone schon als Webcam verwenden.
Oder kannst du es direkt perlen über WLAN wahrscheinlich, ohne dass du irgendwelche Drittanbieter-Apps brauchst.
Bietet eine Alternative zu Passwort und eine verbesserte Suche.
Okay.
Touch-ID oder Face-ID um seine Authentik.
Ganz ehrlich, holt euch einen Ubiqui oder was Vergleichbares und gut ist.
Ups.
Wofür brauchst du ein Dienst-Handy? Keine Ahnung, frag meinen Arbeitgeber, warum die mir eins geben.
Also ich werde nicht oft angerufen, ich wurde aber schon ab und zu mal am Wochenende angerufen.
Und manchmal ist es ja auch so, dass die sagen, ja kann jemand Bereitschaft machen bei diesem Change.
Und wenn man dann sagt, ja mach ich, kriegst natürlich Geld für.
Da muss man auch irgendwie angerufen werden. Ja macht in dem Sinn schon Sinn.
Fraps war vor allem Performance-Fresser ohne Ende.
So sieht es aus, deswegen verkaufe ich auch nichts.
Mach ich, sobald es geht.
Da würde ich sofort investieren, Patrick. Kein Ding, Massive.
Massive Investment-Stonks.
Über wie viele Anteile muss man so halten?
Ich muss ja dann auch was von haben.
Ein Kollege von mir wollte einen VR.
Wie nennt man das?
Also ich sage euch, was er machen wollte.
Ein Kollege von mir und sein Bruder, der ist Spieler-Entwickler, die wollten sich eine Halle mieten und dort VR-Spiele anbieten.
Fand ich von der Idee her cool. Die wollten dann solche Sachen machen, wie sie bauen einen Panzer und du kletterst dann den Panzer und es hieltst dann mit dem MG und sowas in VR.
Bloß, dass du halt wirklich auf den Panzer klettern kannst und es auch merkst.
Die Idee fand ich cool.
Gibt es schon. Es gibt ganz viel schon. Es gibt auch schon viele McDonalds und trotzdem gibt es noch mehr.
Die Idee fand ich nicht schlecht.
Zumindest hat er gesagt, er braucht dafür Startkapital.
Und da sich ein paar Investor-Dudes beraten und er hat mir das erzählt von einem.
Er hat gesagt, er gibt den 50.000 Euro Startkapital dafür, weil die müssen ja auch mal Test-Equipment kaufen.
Mit 50.000 Euro kommst du ja auch nicht wirklich super weit.
Und dafür will er, haltet euch fest, 50% Anteile der Firma haben.
Und da habe ich gesagt, nee. Dann war mir das nicht.
Das war halt irgendwie so ein Dude, der wahrscheinlich in alles irgendwie investiert und halt versucht, dass halt ab und zu mal was wirklich groß wird, wo es dann massiv Geld bringt.
Also, ne, macht er nicht.
Das war im Prinzip auch ganz gut, weil die hatten dann nach einem halben Jahr schon keinen Bock mehr, VR-Sachen zu entwickeln.
Du hast die Geschichte verpasst.
Gut, kurze Zusammenfassung für den Patrick.
Ein Kollege von mir wollte eine Firma aufmachen, eigene VR-Games entwickeln.
Ein Investor-Typ wollte ihm 50.000 Euro geben für 50% Firmenanteile.
Da hat er gesagt, nee.
AC-Movement-VR-Chat. Das ist gefährlich, den Chat irgendwelche Motoren bewegen zu lassen.
Ich würde den Chat keine Motoren hier bei mir bewegen lassen.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt nur zwei Sachen. Ich habe einen World-ETF und Amazon-Aktien.
Und Amazon-Aktien auch nur, also eine Amazon-Aktie, was jetzt ja angeblich mittlerweile 20 sind.
Und auch nur, weil ich gesagt habe, ich kaufe Amazon, als sie bei 2000 Euro waren.
Weil ich keine Ahnung habe von Stonks Zeug.
Groove Electric, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich komme mit dem Chat heute nicht hinterher.
Gibt es Sachen, die du noch anfangen willst? Wie jetzt? Auf was jetzt? Bezogen?
Sachen, die ich noch anfangen will?
Man sagt nicht noch lernen will oder so?
Weiß ich gerade nicht.
Muss ich mir Gedanken drüber machen.
Wie oft benutzt man eigentlich so ein Dienst-Handy? Das kommt wahrscheinlich ganz entscheidend darauf an, was man so macht.
Achso, ich benutze das quasi zu 99% privat.
Die 1%, wo mich da mal jemand anruft oder ich irgendwelche E-Mails lese.
Ne, ne, also ich benutze das zu 99% privat. Ich gucke da YouTube drüber, ich gucke Twitch drüber, ich google drüber, ich habe das dabei, wenn ich wandern gehe.
Ich habe auch kein privates Handy mehr, seitdem ich das habe.
Einzige, was ich machen muss ist, sollte ich mal wirklich kündigen oder die mir kündigen, man weiß ja nie, dann muss ich ein paar 2-Faktor-Authentifizierungen umstellen auf mein privates Handy wieder.
Weil ansonsten, aber dafür habe ich 3 Monate Zeit.
Wann denkst du mit Apple-Metal einstampfen? Ich weiß nicht, wie erfolgreich Metal ist, aber eher nicht so, oder?
Dextory, damit habe ich auch aufgenommen früher, ja. Dextory war aber schon Advanced, das gab es noch nicht so früh.
Wir sind heute echt verwöhnt mit OBS und Sachen wie Shadowplay und sowas.
Und natürlich, wir sind auch verwöhnt einfach mit Rechnern, die ein bisschen Wumms haben, nicht so ein Crap wie irgendein Athlon XP 1900 oder sowas, wo man früher rumgeklebst ist.
Von irgendwelchen Pentium 1, 2 Dingern fange ich mal gar nicht an.
Gut, dafür haben wir heute auch 30 Millionen Abstraktionslayer zwischendurch.
Früher hätte beispielsweise keiner daran gedacht, dass man ein Notizprogramm auf dem Desktop mal in einem Browser laufen lässt.
Ich komme nicht hinterher mit dem Chat.
Ich kenne Twitch-Chat-Plays-Pokemon und sowas. Oder wie die Amis sagen, Pokemon.
Wenig.
Konntest du schon vor der Ausbildung programmieren? Lange davor konnte ich das schon.
Natürlich ist man nie fertig mit Lernen, das muss einem klar sein.
Bring your own device. Also, bei mir in der Firma ist das so, die wollen modern und agil sein und jedes Mal scheitert es dann an der Praxis.
Nach dem Motto, ja, wir machen agilere Abläufe und mehr Eigenverantwortlichkeit in dem und dem Bereich.
Und sobald dann irgendwas gemacht wird, kommen sie dann, ach nee, ach nee, oder was sie bei uns auch beispielsweise gesagt haben ist, ja, Homeoffice groß angekündigt, können wir machen, nur direkt mit der Führungskraft vereinbaren und dann kann man das ganz dynamisch handhaben.
Doch nicht, ach, ich weiß nicht so genau. Immer der gleiche Kram bei uns.
Aber ich finde es ehrlich gesagt sogar ganz gut, weil ich habe gar kein eigenes Device, was ich bringen könnte in dem Fall.
Was ist es so weit? Ernsthaft? Moment, haben die schon aktualisiert? Notifications.
Safari on. iOS, kann es noch nicht. Aber wahrscheinlich der mit iOS 16 dann kommt, oder?
Endlich kann ich da nur zu sagen, wenn das wirklich kommt. Ich meine, so wie ich Apple kenne, ist das wahrscheinlich dann eine Apple eigene Implementierung, die nicht so funktioniert wie der Rest oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das so pauschal sagen kann. Also bei irgendwelchen super großen komplexen Business-Dingern und so, ja, aber wenn man sich überlegt, die, also ich schaue was dran, aber ich finde es ist jetzt nicht so krass, weil wenn man sich überlegt, dass irgendwie zwei Leute oder so damals Rollercoaster Tycoon in der Hälfte in Assembler programmiert haben, das war bestimmt auch complex as fuck.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ja, hast du schon recht, weil das sieht man ja daran, was für krasse Sachen heute mit Unity oder Unreal gemacht werden kann mit 1-2 Leuten. Da hättest du früher ein ganzes Team gebraucht.
Also insgesamt wird es zwar vielleicht komplexer oder es gibt mehr Sachen, aber es gibt halt auch viele Hilfen, die es früher nicht gab. Und man hat heute halt auch gelernt, muss man sagen. Heute weiß man beispielsweise gerade was Games angeht, wie man effizient sinnvoll Sachen löst.
Ich mein, guckt mal, zum Beispiel, es gab hier letztens ein cooles Video, das gucken wir nicht an, das ist ein bisschen zu technisch, ein bisschen zu lang. Irgendeiner hat Mario 64 optimized, ich weiß gar nicht wie das Video hieß. Ja, hier. Fixing Entire Mario 64 Source Code.
Der hat es geschafft. Mario 64. Komplett. Also es gab ja diesen, es gibt ja auf GitHub dieses Mario 64. Es ist nicht decompiled, ist es nicht aus dem Leak? Nee. Oder ist es decompiled? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Nee, die haben das nachprogrammiert.
Nee, ach, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß. Nee, nachprogrammiert haben sie Ocarina of Time. Nachprogrammiert haben sie Ocarina of Time und das Mario 64 ist aus dem Code Leak, oder?
Sowas in der Richtung. Zumindest der Typ hat quasi die Funktionen genommen von Mario 64 und hat halt geguckt, dass der Input und der Output mehr oder weniger gleich bleiben, hat es optimiert. Und er hat es geschafft von 20 auf 60 FPS und das Spiel sieht teilweise noch besser aus. Und das konnte er garantiert nur, weil man halt, seit wann kam Mario 64 raus? 1994 oder so? Nee, 1998 eher so in dem, nee. 1996?
Release Date? 1996, ja. Also man hat halt in 20 Jahren oder 15 Jahren Entwicklungs, Development Geschichte dazu gelernt, wie man Sachen eben gut macht. Und man hat vor allem auch die modernen Tools von heute. Man hat Compiler von heute, wobei bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob ihm das was bringt, aber doch wahrscheinlich. Aber man hat auf jeden Fall Code Optimierung und man hat gelernt, wie man Sachen besser macht.
Und das sieht man daran schon. Also da hat sich schon einiges getan die letzten Jahre. Wohingegen, guckt mal Leute, bei Mario 64 mussten die sich überlegen, wie mache ich das überhaupt mit so einer Kamera? Also wie könnte man eine Kamera programmieren für ein Spiel?
Ich meine, das war eines der ersten 3D-Spiele mit Bewegung in dieser Art. Wie macht man das gescheit, ja? Und heute weiß man das und noch viel mehr, wie man sowas ordentlich macht.
Nintendo ist, was Technik angeht, gerade auf ihrer eigenen Konsole, wirklich erste Sahne. Da kannst du nix sagen. Also Nintendo ist Bleeding Edge, was Technologie angeht. Manchmal machen sie dumme Sachen. Sie machen zum Beispiel weiter P2P-Sachen bei Multiplayer-Spielen und so. Wobei sie nicht genau, was mit Nintendo los ist.
Ja, das ist aber, Pokémon ist ja auch nicht, na doch. Es ist schon Nintendo selbst, aber es ist, wie heißt die, ist das Game Freak? Die kacken rein. Aber bei den Kern, bei diesen Kerngames, wenn die neues Mario entwickelt auf einer neuen Konsole, das ist technisch wirklich immer absolut erste Sahne. Da kannst du nix sagen.
Guckt euch Mario Galaxy an. Mario Galaxy ist, finde ich persönlich, heute noch, und das kann man übrigens auch schön im Emulator hochspielen, Mario Galaxy ist heute immer noch eines der mit Abstand stimmigsten, guckt euch das mal an, eines der mit Abstand stimmigsten Games überhaupt, was es gibt.
Ja, das Ding sah pixellig auf der Wii aus, weil es halt die Wii ist. Aber das Game an sich ist so eine perfekte Mischung aus Artstyle und Grafik und Animationen und da gibt es einfach nichts an dem Game, was stört. Und das ist selten.
Das Game ist nicht perfekt. Ich habe auch ein paar Sachen, die mich genervt haben, aber rein vom Visuellen her ist Mario Galaxy eines der, wirklich der besten, rein von der Optik her, der besten Spiele, die je gemacht wurden. Vom Gesamtpaket her.
Kann man bei Bring Your Own Device sich ein Notebook ausholen? Ja, Bring Your Own Device heißt ja, also bring das Notebook mit. Du kannst das Notebook mitnehmen, was du willst, je nachdem. Mag vielleicht manchmal Firmenpolices geben, dass du manche Geräte nicht nehmen darfst, aber in der Regel nimmst du halt dein Gerät.
Das Problem bei uns ist, wir sagen immer nur, wir wollen agil sein, unterm Strich sind wir es da nie. Wofür denn Web-Notification? Zum Beispiel für PWAs. Der PWA-Support ist auch richtig reudig unter, äh, da fehlt noch ein bisschen was hier, äh, unter iOS.
Da kannst du zum Beispiel eine PWA machen, also eine Progressive Web App, also im Prinzip ist das sowas ähnliches wie eine Webseite, die man auf den Startbildschirm hinzufügen kann, nur dass sie im eigenen Fenster dann läuft und nicht mehr direkt in der Safari App, aber es ist nach wie vor Safari.
Nur, dass sie dir dann auch Notifications schicken kann. Stell dir vor, du hast einen Preistracker als PWA und der soll dir eine Nachricht schicken, wenn das Produkt, was du suchst, äh, unter 1000 Euro fällt. Da kann dir eine Nachricht schicken.
Ja, es fällt, ja. Aber das ist halt das Coole, da sieht man, was eben 15 Jahre an Entwicklungszeit nicht nur bei einem, sondern eben auch bei der gesamten Industrie ausgemacht haben.
Du hast bessere Tools, du hast bessere Libraries, du hast mehr Erfahrungen, du hast mehr Erfahrungen, worauf du zurückgreifen kannst, weil die letzten 15 Jahre, was laber ich, 25 Jahre, wir reden von 1996, 25 Jahre, weil die letzten 25 Jahre auch schon viele Leute dumme Sachen gemacht haben und man jetzt merkt oder weiß, wie man es halt besser machen soll.
Und besser machen kann, ja. Das ist schon ein Unterschied. Ja, Game Freak verkackts. Was, die haben gekämpft, die haben auch irgendwie gefühlt keinen Bock, weil ich war noch nie großer Pokemon- oder Pokemon-Fan, aber die letzten Game Freak-Spiele, die ich gesehen habe, also nicht die letzten, die letzten Pokemon-Spiele, die ich gesehen habe, sahen maximal hässlich aus.
Den bekomme ich auch manchmal, ja. Der macht wirklich gute Videos, wer es nicht kennt, also gerade zu diesem Thema, wer den Channel nicht kennt, kann ich wirklich wärmstens empfehlen.
Der macht richtig, richtig gute Videos, was Games angeht. Und er sieht sich regelmäßig dem Hate der Nintendo-Fans ausgesetzt, weil die das nicht verkraften können, wenn einer sagt, die neuen Pokemon-Games sehen hässlich aus.
Und am schlimmsten ist, wenn irgendeiner schreibt auf Twitter, warum hast du 88 im Benutzernamen? Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten heutzutage los ist, aber ich würde standardmäßig bei einer 88 im Benutzernamen auf Twitter davon ausgehen, dass er 1988 geboren ist und nicht irgendwelche komischen anderen Dinger.
Galaxy ist richtig gut. Mario Galaxy ist in allen Bereichen top. Ich müsste drüber nachdenken, es gab sicherlich Sachen, die mich genervt haben, aber insgesamt finde ich, ist es mit meinem Lieblings-Mario-Game.
Kannst du mir eine gute Seite schicken, wo die WEP, WPA und WPA2 gut und einfach erklärt sind? Das ist gar nicht so einfach. Verschlüsselung ist ein äußerst komplexes Thema.
Das Einzige, was ich dir aus dem Kopf sagen kann, ist, schmeißen wir WEP in die Tonne und WPA und mindestens WPA2.
Was? Ernsthaft? Microsoft, Alter. PaintsChamp. Hey, ich hab den Chat geschafft, Wahnsinn.
Eure Lehrerin hat 2 Minuten über WEP und WPA geredet. Ja gut, er kann es ja nicht, weil er nicht viel Inhalt gehabt hat, oder?
MacBook Pro iOS 16. Na dann. So Leute, komm, wir gucken. Gibt es noch irgendwelche interessanten Videos, die wir gucken könnten?
Ich bin noch eine halbe Stunde da, weil es ist ja schon spät. Steht ja auch, steht ja auch. Das wird dir gefallen.
Hab ich mir auf dem zweiten Bildschirm schon angeguckt, ja. Und ich würde nie den Chat, ich würde nie den Chat ernsthaft Motoren steuern lassen.
Außer ich will, dass ich runterfliege. Ich traue dem Chat dafür nicht genug.
Guck, und der Chat, der schreibt jetzt hier die ganze Zeit, Left, Right.
Ich würde den Chat niemanden, nie Motoren hier steuern lassen.
Sehr cooles Video, das Rickroll kommt jetzt gleich, oder?
Ja, für Rennspiele stelle ich es mir gerade, gerade weil Simracing die letzten 1-2 Jahre Fahrt aufgenommen hat, kann man sagen.
Die krassesten Absturz-Stories. Also ich habe mal auf Rock am Ring einen Rucksack verloren und eine Taschenlampe.
Das zählt aber glaube ich nicht als krasse Absturz-Stories auf Festivals.
Und die restliche Sache von Rock am Ring kennt ihr, da habe ich ein Video zu aufgenommen.
Ich habe da nicht nur meinen Rucksack und die Taschenlampe verloren.
Aber da habe ich ein eigenes Video zugemacht.
Was sind das wieder für Empfehlungen?
Das ist G-Bait. Das Video hier ist hundertprozentig G-Bait.
Ich wette mit euch, das ist G-Bait. Und zwar wird dieses Video folgendermaßen laufen.
Die macht irgendeinen 15 Sekunden Funny TikTok Intro. Wir können mal gucken, ob ich richtig liege.
Die macht irgendeinen 10-15 Sekunden Funny TikTok Intro und dann tut sie so, als würde sie die Wohnung fegen.
Aber so zusammengeschnitten, dass es in Wirklichkeit nur 5 Minuten waren, um das Footage aufzunehmen.
Wetten? Wetten? Übelstes G-Bait. Ich sage es euch.
Okay, Funny Intro. Warum kann man eigentlich nicht vorwärts und rückwärts machen bei diesem...
Okay, 15 Sekunden Funny Intro sind wir schon mal dabei. Man muss das auch nicht hören. Das ist overrated, das zu hören.
Okay, 15 Sekunden Funny Intro sind gleich rum.
Diese Videos sind immer gleich G-Bait. Okay, jetzt sind wir mal bei 20 Sekunden Funny Intro.
So, da ist Meister Propper. Und Zeitraffer geputzt, okay.
Man sieht es noch nicht mal putzen. Es ist einfach G-Bait. Es ist einfach krassester G-Bait wieder.
Von wegen, von wegen hast du die Wohnung geputzt. Von wegen, ganz bestimmt.
Man hat nichts, man hat legit nichts vom Putzen gesehen.
Alter, diese Videos. Vor allem, Moment, warum genau hat das 3,2 Millionen Views?
Okay, das muss man nicht hinterfragen, warum es 3,2 Millionen Views hat. Ich sage dann dazu nur...
Man weiß jetzt nicht, warum manche Videos so viele Aufrufen bekommen. Bestes Video verdient, ja.
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt wissen, ganz wichtig.
Erstmal Waffe inspekten, wie man das aus Call of Duty kennt, alles klar.
Also, sollten demnächst mein Flugzeug irgendwie über Russland abstürzen oder so, dann weiß ich Bescheid.
Gut, kann ich sagen, Jungs, ich bin bereit. Ich habe schon mein YouTube-Video zugesehen.
Wir gucken jetzt aber keine Shorts. Ich mag Shorts gar nicht.
Wie streamt er das? Ach, nee, nee, nee. Ach, der reactet nur. Okay, ich wollte gerade sagen, mit Streamen habe ich schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht.
Okay, gibt es noch irgendwas, was wir uns angucken könnten jetzt in letzter Zeit?
Redwood in 100 Sekunden. Okay, das habe ich nur aufgemacht, weil ich wissen will, was Redwood ist.
Und ich tippe mal drauf, dass Redwood, weil der JavaScript steht, ein weiteres JavaScript-Framework ist, was die Welt unbedingt gebraucht hat.
Alexi Bexy hat heute seine Erfahrungen gemacht. Ja, Apple auch Kackladen. Oh, was ist das? Computer explodes.
Das müssen wir jetzt gucken. Ich will sehen, wie der Computer explodet.
Sieht man, was es ist? Sieht man, was es ist?
Sieht man, was es ist? Nee, kein LC-Power.
Wieso? Passiert doch gar nichts. Oh mein Gott, Jesus Christ, der Lüfter geht an.
Wow. Oh. Wie das war es jetzt? Computer explodes. Ja, übertreib halt.
Oh, das ist aber ordentlich. Das ist aber ordentlich am dampfen. Oh, das brennt. Das brennt, oder?
Nee. Ah, die gute Knibbecks Rohrzange. Wobei, nee, ist es gar nicht. Ist es gar nicht.
Aber der Rechner, das sieht auch aus wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend. Das ist echt mal ein China-Böller-Netzteil.
Also es ist ein Yuan-Tech-Netzteil. Hab ich noch nie gehört. Das ist wahrscheinlich was auf dem gleichen Niveau wie LC-Power.
Okay. Und jetzt, und jetzt lassen wir uns erklären, was Redwood.js ist.
Was sonst? Es gibt auch schon deutlich zu, oh, oh, oh, Leute. Sagt doch was.
Mein Sound war legit. Jeder Stream, jeder Stream, den ich gemacht habe, die letzten paar Tage hatte scheiß Sound.
Und keiner hat was gesagt. MonkaS.
Doch, das läuft hier ins Limit rein.
Es wird auch echt Zeit für ein neues JavaScript-Framework, oder? Es gibt so wenige.
Früher, so nicht zu Boomer-Zeiten, aber früher haben die krassen Startups Ruby und Rails verwendet.
Das ist ja aber total out. Niemand verwendet heute mehr Ruby und Rails, es sei denn, er hat damit angefangen, kommt nicht mehr davon weg.
Ich mag Ruby und Rails und ich mag Ruby. Was macht mein Zabbix? Mein Zabbix, der monitort mein Zeug.
Aber ich hab, ich hab ein paar Sachen noch eingerichtet, aber nicht so viel mehr.
Viel zu wenig Frameworks. Moment.
Das ist kein Framework, das ist quasi ein Metaframework, seh ich das richtig?
Also die nehmen Sachen, die es schon gibt und packen die so zusammen, dass man sie nicht mehr selbst zusammen konfigurieren muss.
Also das ist quasi ein Bloat-Bundle, genau. Also ein Metaframework sozusagen.
Es ist aber JavaScript-Zeug. Irgendwann ist auch mal gut, oder? Übertreibt es halt nicht so.
Im Prinzip ist es mir vollkommen egal. Hauptsache, die haben das ordentlich in ihren Docs drinne stehen, wie es geht.
Ich muss sagen, ich halte von so was nicht sonderlich viel. Weil du lernst ja dann im Prinzip das Metaframework und nicht die eigentlichen Frameworks unten drunter.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich das Wissen, was dich im Endeffekt weiterbringt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so geil ist. Von der Idee her kannst du schnell starten, aber du musst dann trotzdem was lernen.
Die Komplexität wird wahrscheinlich ein bisschen reduziert, aber dafür wirst du dann total erschlagen.
Du fängst dann nicht einfach an und sagst, ok, ich mach mal eine HTML-Seite, mach da ein bisschen Sachen rein, mach da ein bisschen JavaScript rein.
Du fängst dann an mit gleich GraphQL und irgendwelchen Routen definieren und React und das ist teilweise schon...
Du musst ja nicht zwangsläufig SQL schreiben, nur wenn du kein GraphQL verwendest.
Es gibt sich, der Tausend ist jetzt übertrieben, aber einige andere Möglichkeiten, ohne SQL selbst zu schreiben, auf seine Sache in der Datenbank zuzugreifen.
Ah, da ist auch Backend-Zeug dabei. Das heißt, man muss Node.js Backend machen. Auf Node.js Backend hätte ich persönlich wenig Bock.
Ich weiß, viele mögen Node.js und es ist bestimmt auch nicht verkehrt, sein Backend Node.js zu machen. Es gibt sehr viele Packages, es gibt viele Tutorials. Man findet Leute für, also ist das nicht schlecht. Ich bin kein Node.js Fan. Das ist alles.
Wie sage ich Node.js Performance für APIs? Die Node.js Performance ist absolut in Ordnung. Es gibt zig Benchmarks und Blog-Posts und nach dem Motto, ja, Battle of Web-Frameworks.
Ja, das ist dann meistens nicht unbedingt jetzt in den Top 5 Node, aber Node ist schnell genug und darum geht's.
Dafür hat Node andere Vorteile. Du kannst theoretisch manche Sachen zwischen Frontend und Backend shareen. Wie viel das wirklich ist, hängt wahrscheinlich von den Umständen ab.
Und du hast halt NPM und NPM gibt es halt 30 Milliarden Pakete für alles. Es gibt nichts, was es nicht in NPM gibt. Es gibt halt auch viel Shit in NPM.
Es gibt auch sowas wie isOdd und isEven und solche Dinger oder Pakete, die Mailware mit ausliefern oder Pakete, die anlistet werden und dafür Dependencies kaputt machen.
Es gibt den ganzen Wahnsinn mit NPM dabei.
Ich bin mir bei solchen Strukturen immer nicht sicher, ob die nicht nur auf dem Papier gut aussehen, ob die dann in der Praxis auch so gut funktionieren.
Das kann ich aber erst beurteilen, wenn ich es mal verwendet habe.
Also ich bin da immer skeptisch, wenn es so starr vorgegeben ist, ob das dann auch wirklich gut händelbar wird dadurch bei umfangreicheren Sachen. Keine Ahnung.
Ich vermute mal Prisma ist ein Node.js Orm, oder?
Das kann jede x-beliebige GraphQL Library.
Das haben wir sogar im Stream schon gemacht.
Du bist da halt direkt gefickt, wenn du irgendwas machen willst, was sich die Redwood Leute nicht im Vorfeld überlegt haben.
Du willst deployen auf deinen eigenen Linux Server und wenn die sich das nicht überlegt haben, dann funktioniert es nicht richtig.
Dann musst du dann dein eigenes Deploy-Plugin programmieren oder so. Dann fällt wieder die Frage, wie viel dir das an der Arbeit abnimmt.
Wir brauchen ein neues Framework, was Redwood abstrahiert. Ein Meta-Meta-Framework brauchen wir. Computer explodes.
Das wurde mir vorhin empfohlen. So krempelst du dein Leben um. Kurz gesagt macht immer ziemlich gute Videos.
Ich möchte mein Leben nicht umkrempeln, aber vielleicht sage ich jetzt ja, nachdem ich das geguckt habe, wird Zeit.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich habe es jetzt auf die Reihe gekriegt, ein bisschen über 11 Kilo abzunehmen in drei Monaten. Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht das Leben umgekrempelt, aber das ist doch schon mal ein ganz guter Start.
Das Problem dabei ist, es gibt zwei Stufen, das zu erkennen oder erst mal, nein, drei.
Es zu realisieren, dann auch zu sagen, so nach dem Motto, ja, da will man was dran ändern und es dann irgendwann auch zu machen.
Es gibt ja durchaus Sachen, über die macht man sich Gedanken und denkt sich dann, naja, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, warum ich da dran was ändern soll. Zum Beispiel.
Ich interagiere überhaupt nicht gerne mit anderen Menschen. Ich mag auch irgendwelche Meetings mit fremden Leuten, mache nicht und ich telefoniere auch nicht gerne mit fremden Leuten.
Da könnte man sagen, ich mag wenig sozialen Kontakt. Also mit Leuten, die ich kenne und die ich mag, ist das alles nice, aber ich mag nicht viele.
Also sagen wir mal, es gibt Menschen, von 100 Leuten, die die treffen, verstehen die sich mit 50% wunderbar und ich verstehe mich von 100 Leuten mit einem.
So, so ist ungefähr meine Ausbeute. Da will ich aber, das habe ich realisiert, da will ich aber nichts dran ändern.
Also ich habe überhaupt nicht vorne was dran zu ändern. Ich finde das absolut in Ordnung.
Ich habe eine Sache mittlerweile realisiert, dass ich andere Menschen nicht mag.
Oftmals ist es sogar noch schlimmer als nicht mag. Also Großteil der anderen Menschen kann ich überhaupt nicht ab.
Also ich bin quasi nicht rassistisch, ich bin quasi Menschenrassist, falls es so ein Wort gibt.
Also mir ist das egal, ob einer schwarz, rot, grün oder was auch immer ist, aber ich werde ihn wahrscheinlich nicht mögen.
Unabhängig von der Optik werde ich ihn nicht mögen.
Außer den Chat, außer den Chat natürlich ja. Aber wisst ihr warum das mit dem Chat und auf Twitch und so, warum das funktioniert?
Das ist ganz einfach, warum das hier funktioniert. Ich sitze eigentlich hier und schwätze vor mich hin.
Und kann mir dann rauspicken, auf was ich, mit was ich interagiere und mit was nicht.
Ich muss mit euch nicht interagieren, wenn ich nicht will. Und umgedreht ist es ja ähnlich.
Ihr müsst es auch nicht gucken, wenn ihr nicht wollt. Ihr könnt es einfach, Max der Spaß, dann will ich mir nicht angucken.
Aber ich kann die meisten Leute nicht ab. Okay weiter im Text.
Oder einfach nur tatsächlich deinen Hobbys nachzugehen, statt durch Reddit zu scrollen.
Durch Reddit scrollen? Wie oft scrollt ihr so durch Reddit?
Also ich scrolle dank der verkackten Reddit App relativ wenig durch Reddit.
Was ich mache ist, ich lese ein paar Subreddits und da scroll ich aber auch nicht viel.
Weil, naja, die meisten Sachen sind nach 1-2 Seiten, bin ich dann dort angelangt, wo ich die Post schon kenne.
Naja, es gibt sicherlich ein paar Sachen, die schwierig zu erreichen sind, auch wenn man die sich gerne wünscht.
Aber eine Sache, so vielleicht mal, ich versuche mal was motivierendes zu sagen.
Man glaubt gar nicht, wie gut man in was werden kann, oder wie schnell man, oder man wird viel schneller in was gut, als man es sich am Anfang so ausweilt.
Alter, Chain Law ist ja gut, jetzt übertreibt es man nicht.
Man glaubt gar nicht, wie schnell man in was gut werden kann, wenn man anfängt.
Jetzt könnte man dieses Just-Do-It-Meme abspielen, aber es gibt so viele Sachen von Leute, die sagen, ja, sind wir beim aktuellen Thema.
Ah, ich müsste mal abnehmen, oder ach, ich möchte gerne programmieren lernen, oder ach, ich würde gerne mal wieder irgendwie das und das machen,
oder ach, ich würde gerne, keine Ahnung, Klavier spielen lernen, ich würde das und das machen.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, wie oft man daran denkt, dass man das mal gerne machen würde.
Mal genommen, man denkt in einem Abstand von einem halben Jahr oder einem Jahr immer wieder drüber nach.
Und wenn man sich dann überlegt, hätte ich jetzt schon das letzte Mal, wo ich drüber nachgedacht habe, angefangen, dann wäre ich jetzt wahrscheinlich schon relativ gut.
Also man glaubt gar nicht, wie gut man in einem halben Jahr oder in einem Jahr mit manchen Sachen werden kann.
Ich mein, das ist, muss man der Fairness halber auch sagen, diese ganzen Motivationsvideos finde ich auch Schwachsinn.
So nach dem Motto, man muss bloß genug dran glauben, dann kann man alles schaffen.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass es, oder es würde mich, ich würde gerne mal einen Beleg sehen, dass es so ist.
Aber realistisch betrachtet kann nicht jeder alles machen.
Das fängt schon so an mit, was weiß ich, welche Körpergröße hast du.
Oder wenn ich jetzt 38 werde, kann ich nicht sagen, ach, ich würde noch gerne mal in die Bundeswehr Pilot werden oder so.
Es gibt einfach Dinge, die funktionieren nicht, was nicht heißt, dass man nicht gut werden kann in manchen Sachen.
Ich könnte jetzt auch, guck mal, wenn ich jetzt sage, Leute, ich würde gerne Profi Radsportler werden.
Ich kann das noch so viel wollen, das wird realistisch betrachtet niemals so werden.
Ich kann verdammt gut werden, was Fahrradfahren angeht, aber ich werde kein Profi Fahrradfahrer mehr mit 37.
Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Ding, du kannst noch so viele Motivationsvideos gucken, du kannst alles schaffen, du musst nur an dich glauben und sonst wie.
Das basiert oftmals ja auch darauf, dass Leute in diesen Videos dir dann erzählen, guckt mich an, ich habe es auch geschafft.
Das ist aber ein denkbar schlechtes Beispiel, weil für einen, der da steht jetzt in dem Video und es euch erzählen kann,
dass er es geschafft hat und ihr das auch schaffen könnt, haben es wahrscheinlich tausend andere nicht geschafft.
So, aber wie gesagt, das soll eines nicht zweitläufig demotivieren, aber ich denke schon, dass man einen gewissen Realismusbezug braucht, was sinnvoll erreichbar ist.
Und ob die Typen diesem Video das erzählen, dass sie es geschafft haben, ist eh fraglich, ob sie es geschafft haben.
Aber trotzdem, man muss ja nicht gleich zur Weltklasse gehören in allem, weil das wird höchstwahrscheinlich nicht so sein.
Aber man kann, gerade wenn das was ist, was man gerne machen will, man kann in relativ kurzer Zeit verdammt gut in Sachen werden.
Also wenn ihr heute anfängt und sagt, ja, ich würde gerne programmieren lernen und ihr macht wirklich konsequent, kümmert ihr euch mal ein Jahr drum.
Vor allem, wenn das was ist, was so von innen rauskommt, weil ihr das gerne machen wollt und dann damit anfängt und feststellt,
oh, das ist ja wirklich cool, das ist das, was ich auch schon gerne machen wollte.
Und dann bleibt man ja auch automatisch, wenn man sich da mal überholt hat, dann dran, weil man es halt ja nicht grundlos schon immer machen wollte, wenn es einem dann auch gefällt.
Und dann glaubt man, wie gut man in einem Jahr werden kann mit Sachen.
Also wenn jetzt einer sagt, ich würde gerne malen lernen oder zeichnen lernen oder so, ich bin mir sicher, wenn derjenige gar keine Ahnung vom Zeichnen hat
und das aber halt wirklich so aus eigenem Antrieb gerne lernen möchte und es konsequent mal ein Jahr sich damit beschäftigt,
wenn du dir das erste Bild von dem anguckst und das Bild nach einem Jahr, da sind Welten dazwischen.
Das Bild nach einem Jahr würdest du sagen, das sieht schon relativ gut aus.
Ich meine, du kannst es natürlich unterscheiden von einem, der sein Leben lang malt, keine Frage.
Aber du denkst wahrscheinlich nicht, dass er das innerhalb von einem Jahr gelernt hat.
Also man kann ziemlich gut werden in Sachen innerhalb von kurzer Zeit.
Chat, was ist denn mit euch schon wieder los hier? Was geht mit dem Chat ab? Was ist hier los, Alter?
Also dieses Bild verwirrt mich jetzt. Was hast du denn da unter der Decke, wenn da hier nebendran ist?
Los auf Battlefield, nein, ich will das Video jetzt noch fertig gucken, dann geh ins Bett.
Das ist einfach bla bla bla, das Internet erzählt dir viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ich meine, guckt euch diese ganzen, also das hier mit diesem Investieren ist gut.
Es gibt durchaus seriöse Kanäle, es bezieht sich nicht auf alles, was ich jetzt sage.
Zum Beispiel Finanzfluss oder sowas kann man sich alles angucken, das ist alles super, da gibt es nichts dagegen zu sagen.
Aber es gibt in diesem Bereich auch sehr viele shady Seiten und Videos und sonst was.
Und da wird den Leuten nicht etwa erzählt, wie man sinnvoll investiert, sondern es wird erzählt, du brauchst das richtige Mindset.
Wenn du das richtige Mindset hast, dann geht alles von alleine.
Schwachsinn, der Insimodus starten geht dann von alleine.
Aber reich werden mit krassen Investment bestimmt nicht.
Das ist halt so ein dummes Gelaber.
Das Mindset alleine ohne Ahnung bringt dir nichts.
Was meint ihr denn, warum Klaviervirtuosen täglich mehrere Stunden üben?
Also ohne Können und ohne Übung geht da nichts.
Also das Mindset alleine führt höchstens dazu, dass du dir einredest, du bist der richtig krasse Checker.
Im Wirklichkeit lachen dich aber alle aus, weil du keine Ahnung hast.
In allen Bereichen gibt es in der IT auch genug Leute, die einfach nur schwätzen können und keine Ahnung haben.
Wahrscheinlich selber meinen sie, sie sind die großen Checker.
Ist das einzig und allein dein Fehler?
Das Üben ist in dem Fall nicht das Mindset.
Das Mindset ist, dass du ans große Geld glauben musst, was die dir immer für einen Bullshit erzählen.
Und dann kannst du dich in ein Auto setzen und die 200er-Scheine aus dem Fenster raussprühen.
Ein Erfolg, wolltest du es einfach nicht genug und hast das Scheitern nur dir zuzuschreiben.
Aber Veränderung ist tatsächlich sehr schwierig.
Wie die meisten Dinge im Leben wird aber auch sie einfacher, wenn wir verstehen, wie sie zustande kommt.
Es ist übrigens auch gar nicht schlimm, wenn man manchmal Sachen verkackt.
Realistisch betrachtet verkackt man in seinem Leben mehr als Dinge, die glatt laufen.
Man lernt auch viel durch Try und Error.
Wahrscheinlich verkackt man von 10 Sachen 9 und macht einen richtig auf lange Sicht betrachtet.
Gut ist dann halt, wenn man die Sachen nicht mehrfach verkackt oder nicht immer wieder verkackt.
Oder manchmal hilft es auch, wenn man den Sachen aus dem Weg geht, weil man weiß, es liegt mir halt nicht.
Als wenn man Sachen verkackt ist ja nicht schlimm.
Der Dschungel.
Stell dir dein Gehirn als üppigen, dichten Dschungel vor.
Dich zu entscheiden, etwas zu tun ist, wie sich durch einen richtigen Dschungel zu kämpfen.
Es ist schwierig und braucht Energie.
Dein Gehirn mag keine Energieverschwendung, deshalb hat es sich einen Trick ausgedacht.
Mein Gehirn mag keine Energieverschwendung, ich mag eher Energieaufnahme als Energieverschwendung.
Handlungen und dein Verhalten hinterlassen Wege im Gehirn-Dschungel.
Fängst du etwas Neues an, trampelst du ein paar Pflanzen nieder und machst dadurch kleine provisorische Pfade ins Dickicht.
Je öfter du das Neue tust, umso deutlicher wird der Pfad.
Mit der Zeit wird daraus ein besser begehbarer Weg, weshalb du ihn jetzt öfters nimmst, wodurch er wiederum zu einer Straße wird.
Und während du das Neue wiederholst, immer wieder, über Jahre, wird die Straße zu einer Autobahn.
Sie zu nehmen ist mühelos, vertraut und bequem.
Je ausgeprägter die Autobahnen in deinem Gehirn.
Umso mehr gewöhnst du dich an diese Bequemlichkeit, also benutzen wir sie ständig, was bedeutet, dass wir meistens das tun, was wir schon immer getan haben.
Und deshalb ist Veränderung so schwierig, besonders als Erwachsener.
Wenn der Gehirn-Dschungel schon...
Gut, eins, man muss das Gehirn-Dschungel schon öffnen.
Man muss aber auch sagen, ich gehe auch mal davon aus, dass es in gewisser Art und Weise evolutionstechnische Gründe hat.
Das würde mich, sage ich, ich weiß nicht, ob es stimmt, aber es würde mich nicht wundern.
Erstens, Energie sparen ist gut.
Und zweitens, Sachen, wo man die Erfahrung gemacht hat, dass sie ungefähr nicht so gut ist, dass sie nicht so gut ist.
Sachen, wo man die Erfahrung gemacht hat, dass sie ungefährlich sind und gut funktionieren, ist ja im Prinzip clever, das wieder so zu machen.
Weil, ich meine, wenn ich irgendwo in der Steinzeit bin, ja, und weiß jetzt, ich nehme lieber den rechten Weg, da passiert mir nichts.
Mich würde vielleicht schon interessieren, was linksrum ist.
Aber der letzte, der linksrum gelaufen ist, der kam nie wieder.
Und rechtsrum passiert mir nicht. Ja gut, da laufe ich halt immer rechtsrum.
Das ist so, das ist safe.
Also, es gibt bestimmt genug Leute, die dann sagen, so Entdeckerdrang haben und sagen, ich gucke jetzt aber trotzdem, was links ist.
Aber die meisten werden wahrscheinlich sagen, ich weiß, rechtsrum ist alles in Ordnung, gehe ich rechtsrum.
Es ist ja auch nicht blöd.
Wenn du überlebst, kannst du dich fortpflanzen.
Wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Also wahrscheinlich stammen wir mehr oder weniger von ziemlichen Langweilern zum größten Teil ab.
Weil die, die irgendwelche gefährlichen Dinge gemacht haben, die haben es wahrscheinlich nicht überlebt.
Das stimmt tatsächlich. Seitdem ich jedes Mal, also seitdem ich jeden Tag eins bis zwei Stunden,
oder mittlerweile sind es eigentlich eher eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden, wandern gehe oder laufen gehe,
mir fehlt tatsächlich was, wenn ich nicht mache.
Aber ich werde nie vom Wecker wach, auch wenn ich früh aufstehen muss, ich bin immer vorher wach.
Also auch als ich 5 vor 45 aufstehen musste, ich bin nie vom Wecker wach geworden.
...vorstellen, der langsam und analytisch vorgeht und verantwortlich ist für Strategien und Sachen wie Kopfrechnen.
Der Planer denkt an die Zukunft und bezieht sorgfältig mit ein, was du erreichen möchtest.
Darauf basierend wählt er, bestimmte Handlungen und bestimmte Ergebnisse zu erzielen,
auch wenn diese Ziele ungemütlich sind, zum Beispiel nach dem Aufstehen direkt zu duschen.
Mit der Zeit werden aus Routinen Gewohnheiten, die dir sehr viel leichter fallen,
denn sie sind quasi eine Abfolge von Aktionen, über die du schon gar nicht mehr nachdenkst.
Hat ja auch seinen Vorteil, man vergisst nichts.
Gut, dass dein Gehirn sie als belohnend empfindet und als gute Reaktion auf bestimmte Situationen ansieht.
Gewohnheiten fühlen sich deshalb an, als wärst du auf Autopilot.
Zu Gewohnheiten musst du dich nicht überreden.
Aber Karl S. würde uns jetzt erzählen, dass du so nicht auf den Mount Everest kommst.
Du tust sie einfach.
Wichtig ist dabei, Gewohnheiten werden von bestimmten Triggern ausgelöst.
Auslösereizen, die aus Einzelheiten oder ganzen Situationen bestehen können.
Sie signalisieren deinem Gehirn, ein bestimmtes Verhalten oder eine Handlung anzustoßen.
In deinem Leben gibt es bereits viele solche Trigger.
Zum Beispiel, dass du dein Handy fast immer entsperrst, sobald du es siehst.
Oder, dass du dich automatisch anschnalzt, sobald du dich ins Auto setzt.
Das ist ja durchaus eine sinnvolle Handlung, oder?
Jedes Mal auch einen Keks kaufst, wenn du dir einen Morgen Kaffee holst,
selbst wenn du gar keinen Hunger hast.
Gewohnheiten werden von einem impulsiven Kleinkind ausgeführt.
Es reagiert auf deine unmittelbaren Wünsche, je nachdem, was sich um dich herum befindet,
ohne langfristige Ziele abzuwägen.
Dieses Kleinkind kennt keine Zukunft und hasst harte Arbeit.
Nimmt es also einen Trigger wahr, lotst es dich zu diesem einfacheren Weg in deinem Gehirn,
der zu bekannten, lohnenden Zielen führt.
Wenn du Kaffee holst, will das Kleinkind auch den Keks dazu.
Einfach nur, weil du das jeden Morgen so machst.
Mit genau diesem Gefühl der Belohnung beginnen die meisten deiner schlechten Gewohnheiten.
Schokolade ist lecker und auf Reddit rumzusurfen kann ab und zu Spaß machen.
Dieses lohnende Gefühl, das mit dem Verhalten verknüpft ist, wollen wir immer wieder haben.
Und so entsteht eine schlechte Gewohnheit.
Erst mal eine Runde Lootboxes kaufen und aufmachen für 100 Euro.
Das Kleinkind klingt wie ein eingebauter Sabotagemechanismus,
ist es genauso wichtig wie der vernünftige Planer.
Meistens arbeiten die zwei auch erfolgreich zusammen.
Du brauchst den vernünftigen Planer, um über große Dinge nachzudenken,
seitwärts einzuparken und deine Steuererklärung auszufüllen.
Aber alles den weisen Planer machen zu lassen, würde viel zu viel Energie kosten.
Indem dein Gehirn banale, sich wiederholende Tätigkeiten als Gewohnheiten auslagert,
die vom Kleinkind gesteuert werden, kriegt dein Gehirn deinen Alltag gebacken,
während es gleichzeitig komplexere mentale Herausforderungen bewältigt.
Wollen wir uns also verändern und ein neues Verhalten etablieren, können wir uns das mit...
Warum sieht das Kleinkind menschlich aus und der Planer ist irgendeine Ente?
Mit genau diesen Energiesparmaßnahmen einfacher machen.
Wir konzentrieren uns mal auf kleine Dinge, nichts Großes.
Besser das Leben ein kleines bisschen besser zu machen, als zu hohe Ziele zu setzen
und dann gar nichts zu verändern.
Vor allem, weil kleine Veränderungen über Monate und Jahre ganz schön was bewegen können.
Wie du eine Gewohnheit bastelst.
Willst du Veränderungen einfacher machen, erzwingst du sie besser nicht durch reine Willenskraft,
sondern überzeugst dein Gehirn, dass sie gar keine große Sache sind,
indem du neue Routinen kreierst, die dann zu Gewohnheiten werden.
Du willst, dass der weise Planer den ersten Pfad baut und dann das Kleinkind ins Spiel bringt,
um die Handlung irgendwann mühelos anzustoßen.
Sagen wir mal, du möchtest mehr Sport treiben, damit du fitter wirst.
Ein Ziel, das viele haben.
Als erstes legst du für dieses ziemlich unklare Ziel
eine Reihe von kleinen, klar umrissenen Handlungen fest.
Wisst ihr, was auch funktioniert?
Schmerzen.
Wenn euch euer Rücken oder eure Gelenke oder was auch immer so wehtun
und ihr wisst genau woran es liegt,
dann ist die Chance relativ hoch, dass ihr was dran ändert.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mein?
Mal angenommen, ihr sitzt wie ich früher den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner.
Nicht nur acht Stunden auf der Arbeit, sondern acht Stunden noch mal daheim.
Und euch tut der Rücken weh.
Und ihr habt die ganze Zeit Kopfweh und ihr habt irgendwelche Probleme.
Und irgendwann ist das so abfuck und so ätzend,
dass ihr dann irgendwann sagt, ich habe zwar keinen Bock drauf,
aber vielleicht sollte ich mich mal werbewegen.
Und dann fangt ihr an, von der Arbeit nicht direkt an den Bahnhof zu gehen,
sondern einen Bahnhof weiter zu laufen für eine halbe Stunde am Tag.
Und dann stellt ihr fest, hey, das ist ja gar nicht schlecht.
Und euch tut das alles nicht mehr so weh.
Also Schmerzen können auch motivierend sein.
Also indirekt.
Die motivieren dich.
Sag mal, das Anstrengen ist weniger nervig, wie dass dir der Rücken weh tut.
Das klappt auch.
Die erste Handlung sollte möglichst niederschwellig sein.
So niedrig, dass sie machbar ist.
Und so klar, dass du nicht viel darüber nachdenken musst.
Eine konkrete, kontrollierbare Handlung könnte zum Beispiel sein,
jeden Morgen zehn Kniebeugen zu machen.
Was meint ihr, wie schnell ihr lernt, zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung,
ihr wollt euch abgewöhnen, den linken Schuh immer zuerst anzuziehen.
Oder so was.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ihr den linken Schuh zuerst anzieht,
sticht euch das Schuh mit einer Nadel in den Fuß.
Was meint ihr, wie schnell ihr lernt, mit dem rechten Schuh anzufangen?
Das dauert keine zwei Tage.
Das geht zack.
Ich mein, das will man nicht, aber das geht bestimmt schnell.
Am Anfang kannst du also versuchen, eine Routine zu kreieren.
Während du gleichzeitig auch eindeutige Trigger einbaust,
auf die das Kleinkind später leicht anspringt.
Denk dann, ein Trigger ist nichts anderes als ein Auslöser,
der immer mit der Handlung in Verbindung gebracht wird.
Das können visuelle Hinweise sein,
zum Beispiel etwas Bestimmtes zu sehen, wie deine Trainingssachen.
Oder eine bestimmte Tageszeit.
Oder ein bestimmter Ort, wie ein nahe gelegener Park.
Alles zusammen verstärkt den Befehl.
Das stimmt, da ist aber schon was dran.
Ich guck beispielsweise immer morgens und mittags in die Wetter-App.
Und überleg mir anhand dessen, wo ich mittags hin zum Laufen gehe.
Oder wo ich morgens, wenn ich frei hab, schon hingehe.
Das hilft tatsächlich.
Der Trick bei der Sache ist,
dass du die Handlung immer in einem bestimmten Kontext ausführst.
Dieser Trigger wird dann zum Startknopf,
der die Handlung mit der Zeit automatisch auslösen wird.
Ja, ich laufe, ich laufe, aber nicht, ich laufe.
Ich geh wandern, ich geh nicht joggen.
Als erste deine neue Fitnessroutine mit 10 Kniebeugen anzufangen,
könntest du dabei zum Beispiel immer deine Sportsachen tragen.
Und die Kniebeugen immer zur gleichen Zeit am gleichen Ort machen.
Zum Beispiel um 8 Uhr früh in deinem Wohnzimmer.
Ich bin 15 Kilometer gelaufen.
Brauchst du das nur noch regelmäßig zu wiederholen?
Was sagt denn meine Health-App?
Brauchst du das lange genug, wird aus der Routine eine Gewohnheit.
Aus dem Pfad eine Autobahn.
Nicht falsch verstehen.
Die Kniebeugen werden immer noch Energie kosten.
Aber die Entscheidung, mit den Kniebeugen überhaupt loszulegen,
wird sich nicht mehr nach einer Aufgabe anfühlen.
Meine Health-App sagt, ich hab today 19.230 Schritte gemacht.
Wie viele Kilometer da sind, keine Ahnung.
Steht nicht da.
Gestern Sonntag?
Wisst ihr, wie viele Schritte ich am Sonntag hatte?
Geiler, krasser Vergleich, Alter.
Also heute hab ich 19.230.
Gestern hatte ich 33.
33 und heute ungefähr 20.000.
Gibt's doch Leute, die Civilization spielen.
Steuern? Nee, das werd ich nie gerne machen.
Ich bin ein Typ-Dicker-Mensch.
Es dauert zwischen 15 und 250 Tagen,
bis eine neue Gewohnheit durch einen Trigger automatisch ausgelöst wird.
Wie lange es bei dir dauern wird, kannst du vorher nicht wissen.
Einfach mal anzufangen, ist oft überraschend leicht.
Vor allem die ersten ein, zwei Wochen.
Wenn man dann mal zurückguckt, wird man feststellen,
wie gut man schon geworden ist in der kurzen Zeit.
Dann dran zu bleiben, jeden Tag, ist schwer.
Aber mit der Zeit wird es einfacher.
Also mich motiviert es, wenn ich auf die Waage gucke
und es ist wieder weniger geworden.
5-Hat, letzter Satz.
Wie viele Kilo hast du?
Ich hab jetzt 97,6.
Also ungefähr ein Kilo seit letzt... seit 10...
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich glaub, vor 10 Tagen hab ich das letzte gepost.
Also in 10 Tagen ungefähr ein Kilo.
Was natürlich nicht wirklich so weitergeht.
Das schwankt immer ein bisschen.
Wie groß ich bin? 69 Inches.
Ich finde es witzig, jeder denkt, ich erzähle,
ich gebate ihn jetzt.
Aber ich bin 69 Inches.
Ein bisschen kleiner, aber 69 Inches kann man sich gut merken.
Es ist ein bisschen weniger, aber nicht nennenswert.
69 Inches oder 69 Zoll könnte man auch sagen.
Ounces? Okay, Sekunde.
Wollen wir achten?
Also 3456,85 Ounces.
Alles klar.
Kokona Freedom Units.
Wie viele Sehmeilen.
Es kommt als nächstes Energieverbrauch von 2000 Schritten in BPU pro Stunde.
Nee, BTU. BTU pro Stunde heißt es.
Die bescheuertste Einheit aller Zeiten.
Okay, es ist 22.17, Leute.
Ausrufezeichen spät im Chat.
Was ist es?
Es ist schon spät.
Boomer müde.
Leute, wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Macht's gut.
Bye, bis dann.